not all 13 to 19 year olds are the same
but the one General piece of advice that
I think would really resonate is are you
parenting them based on what you've seen
from them in the first 13 to 19 years of
their life or are you parenting them
based on societal acceptance or the way
you were parented or the way that you
think people will judge them on how you
parent them are you parenting them are
you parenting from a place of your own
selfish Place many parents misstep
because they're selfish and not selfless
are you forcing them to be an engineer
and a doctor because that's the culture
you're from and you think they'll make
more money and then they'll be stable
and happy when they're an artist
that